TODAY'S HEARING OF THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON ACCOUNTABILITY AND
ADMINISTRATIVE REVIEW. BEFORE
WE GET STARTED A COUPLE OF
HOUSEKEEPING ITEMS I WE ARE
REQUIRING THAT MASKS BE WORN BY
ALL MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TESTIFYING HERE IN THIS ROOM IF
YOU DO NOT HAVE A MASK WE CAN
PROVIDE ONE FOR YOU. I WE HAVE
A FEW DIFFERENT OPTIONS TODAY
FOR WITNESS TESTIMONY IF ANY
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC WHO IS
HERE IN THE ROOM LIKE TO
TESTIFY ANNABELLE PLEASE RAISE
YOUR HAND AND I WILL ASK YOU TO
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. WE DO ASK
THAT THE PUBLIC NOT TOUCH THE
MICROPHONE AT YOU MAY EXIT THE
HEARING ROOM WHICH WERE DONE
TESTIFYING OR RETURN TO YOUR
SEAT. I REMOTE TESTIMONY
STATIONS ARE ALSO AVAILABLE
THEY ARE LOCATED OUTSIDE ON THE
NORTH SIDE OF THE CAPITOL. THE
STATIONS ARE AVAILABLE FOR
PRIMARY WITNESSES AS WELL AS
FOR ME TO WITNESS SAYS. FOR
DIALING WITNESSES WILL BE WE
WILL BE USING A MODERATED
TELEPHONE SERVICE AT AND ANY
WITNESSES CAN USE THIS TO
TESTIFY ON A BILL. THE CALL IN
NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING IS.
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. AND THE
ACCES CODE IS. ONE THREE ONE
FIVE FOUR THREE SEVEN YOU CAN
ALSO FIND THIS NUMBER ON THE
ASSEMBLY ACCOUNTABILITY AND
ADMINISTRATIVE REVIEW
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. AS WELL AS
ON YOUR TV SCREEN. IF YOU WERE
CALLING N. PLEASE PLAN TO DO SO
AS SOON AS POSSIBLE AS WE HAVE
ONLY A LIMITED NUMBER OF BILLS
ON TODAY'S AGENDA. AFTER
CALLING IN PLEASE REMEMBER TO
ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND NOISE
THIS INCLUDES MUTING YOUR
LIVESTREAM BROADCAST AND YOUR
SMART DEVICES TO REDUCE ANY
SOUND DISTORTION. IF YOU'RE
HAVING ANY PROBLEMS WITH THE
MODERATED PHONE SERVICE YOU CAN
CALL THE COMMITTEE AT. NINE ONE
SIX THREE ONE NINE THREE SIX
ZERO ZERO. AND MY STAFF WILL BE
THERE TO ASSIST. I ALSO WANT TO
NOTE THAT WE ARE ACCEPTING
WRITTEN TESTIMONY THROUGH THE
POSITION LETTER PORTAL ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. I NOW A
COUPLE OF ADDITIONAL
ANNOUNCEMENTS FOR THE BILLS
BEING TAKEN UP TODAY WE WILL
TAKE NO MORE THAN TWO PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. AND TWO
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. THESE WITNESSES
WILL HAVE TWO MINUTES EACH TO
PROVIDE THEIR TESTIMONY ALL
SUBSEQUENT WITNESSES SHOULD
STATE THEIR NAME THEIR
ORGANIZATION. AND THEIR
POSITION ON THE BELL ONLY. WE
HAVE ONE FELL ON OUR PROPOSED
CONSENT CALENDAR FOR TODAY FILE
ITEM FIVE S. B. EIGHT TWENTY
EIGHT. AND FINALLY FILE ITEM
FOR SB SEVEN SEVEN EIGHT WAS
PULLED BY THE AUTHOR FROM
TODAY'S HEARING. OUT WE DO NOT
HAVE A QUORUM BUT THAT WE CAN
GO AHEAD AND BEGIN AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE. LET'S SEE IF WE
HAVE ANY AUTHORS JOINING US.
YES WE DO HELLO SENATOR PAN.
RIGHT THANKS VERY MUCH MADAM
CHAIR AND I KNOW EVERYONE'S
BOUNCING BETWEEN COMMITTEES
HERE BUT THAT THANKS SO MUCH
FOR GIVING US OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT. SB SEVENTEEN. WHICH IS
A BILL THAT WOULD OPPOSITE
ABOLITION OFFICE OF RACIAL
EQUITY AND RACIAL EQUITY
ADVISORY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
COUNCIL NOR TO ADDRESS SYSTEMIC
AND INSTITUTIONAL RACISM.
THERE'S A THAT HAS RESULTED IN
NOT ONLY POOR HEALTH OUTCOMES
AND DISPARITIES IN THE STATE
BUT OTHER. POOR OUTCOMES AS
WELL THIS BILL IS LONG OVERDUE
IS THE DOWN PAYMENT TOWARD THE
STATE PLAYING A MORE ACTIVE
ROLE IN DISMANTLING OVER THREE
HUNDRED YEARS OF RACIAL
INEQUITIES. AND TRYING AND
ENDING SYSTEMIC RACISM.
EXTENSIVE RESEARCH HAS
IDENTIFIED RACISM AS A PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISIS LEADING TO
SIGNIFICANT HEALTH DISPARITIES.
INCLUDING DISPARITIES IN INFANT
AND MATERNAL MORTALITY CHRONIC
DISEASE PREVALENCE LIFE
EXPECTANCY. AND EVEN COVERED
MORTALITY THIS PANDEMIC AND
CERTAINLY MANY MORE. AND WHILE
THE STATE HAS MADE EFFORTS TO
ACKNOWLEDGE AND CONFRONT RACIAL
DISPARITIES IN RECENT YEARS.
EQUITIES OFTEN BEEN TREATED AS
AN AFTERTHOUGHTOR THE SILENCE
STRATEGY. THIS BILL WILL
ESTABLISH AN OFFICE OF RACIAL
EQUITY WHICH WILL COORDINATE
AND LEAD CALIFORNIA'S EFFORTS
IN EXAMINING AND ENDING
SYSTEMIC RACISM. AND HOLDING
OUR SELVES ACCOUNTABLE TO
ADDRESSING THIS LONG STANDING
ISSUE I HAVE AMENDMENTS THAT
WOULD CLARIFY THE ROLE OF THE
OFFICE OF RACIAL EQUITY IN
RELATION TO THE GOVERNOR'S
CHIEF EQUITY OFFICER WHICH IS
PROPOSED IN THIS YEAR'S BUDGET.
WE WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION AND THIS
COMMITTEE TO ENSURE THAT THE
OFFICE CAN EFFECTIVELY CARRY
OUT ITS DUTIES AND MEET THE
GOALS ESTABLISHED IN THIS BILL.
SB SEVENTEEN IS SPONSORED AND
SUPPORTED BY A WIDE ARRAY OF
STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING LABOR
LOCAL GOVERNMENT ADVOCATES
COMMUNITIES ORGANIZATIONS
HEALTH PROVIDERS AND PUBLIC
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS. THAT
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE I DO HAVE TO CO SPONSORS
WHO WILL BE TESTIFYING SUPPORT
THE BILL ELENA SANTA MARIA OUT
WITH NEXT IN CALIFORNIA AND
CREEK SAMUELS WITH THE
COMMUNITY COALITION SPECIALLY
AT THE PRIVATE THANK YOU.
WONDERFUL AND I JUST TO CONFIRM
I KNOW YOU'VE BEEN WORKING WITH
MY COMMITTEE STEPHENS
AMENDMENTS. THE AMENDMENTS
WOULD ADD H. CHIEF EQUITY
OFFICER WITHIN COPS TO WORK
WITH THE OFFICE OF RACIAL
EQUITY. AND STATE AGENCIES TO
IMPLEMENT THESE NEW
REQUIREMENTS ASSEMBLY YOU HAVE
AGREED TO TAKE THAT AMENDMENT
YES WONDERFUL THANK YOU. BYE
AND AS YOU SAID WE'VE GOT TO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. OUR
MODERATOR PLEASE CAN YOU
CONNECT US WITH. KIRK SAMUELS.
FROM THE COMMUNITY COALITION.
BOTH TIMES ARE OPEN. ALL RIGHT
HELLO THERE GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS CLARK
SPANIELS AND I'M CALLING TO
SPEAK ON- SPEAK WITH YOU ALL
TODAY ABOUT SB SEVENTEEN OUR
RECORDS- THE DIRECTOR OF CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT FOR NONPROFIT
LOCATED IN SOUTH LOS ANGELES
CALL COMMUNITY COALITIONS
VALUES ARE CENTERED ON
ADVANCING RACIAL EQUITY AND
SOCIAL JUSTICE I'M ALSO
SPEAKING TO YOU ALSO BLACK MAN
IN AMERICA WHO IS COGNIZANT OF
THE MOMENT OUR NATION IS IN AND
WHAT IS AT STAKE. I WAS
SPEAKING WITH YOU ALL TODAY- SB
SEVENTEEN BECAUSE I WITNESSED
THE GREATEST OUTCRY FOR RACIAL
JUSTICE I'VE EVER SEEN IN MY
ENTIRE LIFE JUST ONCE OVER A
YEAR AGO WE ALL WATCHED IN
HORROR AS GEORGE FORD WAS
SENSELESSLY MURDERED LAST
SUMMER AN OUTCRY FOR JUSTICE AT
PUBLIC BERKELEY AFTER THAT MANY
HAVE CALLED OF RACIAL RECKONING
GRAYSON RECKONING FOR THIS
COUNTRY ON ON THE HILLS OF THIS
TRAGEDY WE SEE WE ARE SEEING
THE ENEMIES OF DEMOCRACY FIGHT
TO SUPPRESS VOTING RIGHTS
TARGETED AT BLACK COMMUNITIES
AND OTHER COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
HILL CRITICAL POLICE REFORM
POLICIES THAT COULD MOVE US
FORWARD AN OUTRIGHT DECLINE AND
BE FINE EFFORTS TO TEACH GREAT.
ACTUAL HISTORY IN OUR SCHOOLS-
THE CHOICE. WE ARE MAKING HERE
COUPLE. WILL HAVE AN IMPACT ON
THE FORESEEABLE FUTURE AND HAVE
TO PUT. POTENTIAL TO EITHER
UPLOAD EFFORTS TO STEER THIS
COUNTRY CALL- BACKWARDS INTO A
DEEP HARM OF ALL OR BE A BEACON
OF LIGHT. THIS COUNTRY NEEDS
THAT CAN HELP SET A NEW TONE IN
PASSPORT. CALIFORNIA DOES
MATTERS IMMENSELY. AT THE STATE
WE HAVE BEEN AT THE FOREFRONT
OF PASSING SOME OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT POLICIES TO HELP INTO
STRUCTURAL HARM A CHRONIC
DISINVESTMENT. THAT PERPETUATED
RACIAL DISPARITIES ACROSS
COMMUNITIES FROM TAXING THE
WEALTHIEST CALIFORNIA TO HELP.
FUND OUR EDUCATION HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM TO REQUESTED BY LOW
LEVEL NONVIOLENT FELONIES AS
MISDEMEANORS HELPAGE. BEFORE
YOU HAVE MADE GIANT STRIDES TO
ATTEMPT TO CREATE AND STATE
THAT PRIORITIZES EFFORTS TO
MAKE A MORE JUST AND EQUITABLE
FUTURE FOR EVERYONE. AND WHILE
THESE EFFORTS ARE COMMENDABLE.
WE KNOW THAT THERE IS A LONG
ROAD AHEAD OF US AND MUCH MORE
WORK TO BE DONE THIS IS WHY I
BELIEVE THAT YOU ALL SHOULD
BILL I ON SB SEVEN SPEAKING.
ESTABLISHING AN OFFICE THAT CAN
IMPLEMENT A STATEWIDE FRAMEWORK
ON RACIAL EQUITY THAT CAN
RECOMMEND STRATEGIES AND
POLICIES THAT ADVANCE RACIAL
EQUITY ACROSS STATE AGENCIES
AND DEPARTMENTS IS GROUND
BREAKING. WE KNOW THAT THIS
GROUND BREAKING POLICY WON'T
FIX STRUCTURAL RACISM BY ITSELF
BUT IT DOES PUT A STAKE IN THE
GROUND. AND AT THE STATE OF
WHERE OUR VALUES ARE HERE IN
LOS ANGELES I SEE MANY OF MY
COLLEAGUES AND COMRADES.
TIRELESSLY ORGANIZE AND FIGHT
FOR CHANGE THE NAME IN AND
MOVING HACKERS TO ADDRESS ANTI
BLACK RACISM IN ITS MANY FORMS
TO ENSURING THAT CHILDREN IN
OUR COMMUNITIES HAVE HEALTHY
FOOD OPTIONS IN THEIR
NEIGHBORHOOD AND THE TOOLS THEY
NEED. AND SCHOOLS TO SUPPORT
THEIR BIGGEST AND BRIGHTEST
FUTURES- THIS FRAMEWORK
INCREASE ACCOUNTABILITY. WHICH
CAN LEAD TO REAL STRUCTURAL
CHANGES THAT WILL POSITIVELY
IMPACT MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIA.
CENTRALLY LEAD- THE LEAD BY.
FOR THE REST OF THE- SO IN
CLOSING I AM RESPECTFULLY
ASKING FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MR SAMUELS AND
REMOVED HER NEXT WITNESS I'M
JUST GONNA PAUSE FOR A MOMENT
TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM SECRETARY
PLEASE CAN YOU CALL THE ROLL.
PETRIE-NORRIS PRESENT PETER
NORRIS PRESENT PATTERSON. BURKE
BURKE PRESIDENT GRANT. LACKEY
LACKEY PRESENT MEDINA MEDINA
PRESENT RODRIGUEZ. THANK YOU I
ENDIVE MODERATOR IF YOU CAN
PLEASE CONNECT US WITH A LAN S.
SANTA MARIA FROM NEXT IN
CALIFORNIA. AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME'S ALAINA
CENTENARIAN ON THE POLICY
ADVISOR NEXT IN CALIFORNIA
THANKS IN CALIFORNIA IS A
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION
DEDICATED TO SUPPORTING AND
ADVOCATING FOR SYSTEMIC POLICY
AND PROGRAMMATIC SOLUTIONS TO
ADDRESS RACISM. AND ITS ROLE IN
EXACERBATING THE GLARING HEALTH
EDUCATIONAL AND CRIMINAL
JUSTICE CLIMATE AND HOUSING
DISPARITIES WE SEE TODAY. AFTER
AN ANALYSIS OF THE INITIAL
IMPACT OF THE PANDEMIC TOOK ON
THE PEOPLE WHO CALL CALIFORNIA
HOME IT'S CLEAR TO SEE THE
IMPACT OF RACISM AND RACIST
PRACTICES ARE ALIVE AND WELL.
ONE CLEAR EXAMPLE OF THIS NEED
TO ADDRESS SYSTEMIC RACISM CAN
BE FOUND WITHIN THE GOVERNMENT
SPONSORED PRACTICE OF REDLINING.
ALTHOUGH THOSE PRACTICES
OCCURRED SEVENTY YEARS AGO
CALIFORNIANS WHO LIVE IN THOSE
AREAS TODAY. SHOULDER THE
BURDEN OF DELIBERATE POLICY
CHOICES OF THE PAST POOR
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
GENTRIFICATION THROUGH DESERT
POOR AIR QUALITY LACK OF A
RELIABLE INTERNET AND OTHER
FACTORS IMPEDE A PERSON'S
UPWARD MOBILITY. THIS CONDITION
OF LIVING IS UNACCEPTABLE AND
SHOULD NOT REMAIN THE STATUS
QUO AS WE RECOVER FROM THE
PANDEMIC. SB SEVENTEEN SIXTY AT
THE TOP INSTITUTIONALIZED
ADDRESSING SYSTEMIC RACISM BY
PUTTING IN EQUITY AT THE
FOREFRONT OF THE STATE THINKING
VERSUS THE BACK END. DELIBERATE
POLICY CHOICES OF THE PAST
REQUIRED DELIBERATE POLICY
SOLUTION NOW. TO MEDIATE
HORRIBLE PUTTING THE STATE ON A
TRAJECTORY OF BEING ANTI RACIST.
CURRENTLY THE STATE OPERATED
EQUITY WORKING WITH IT IN SILOS
WITHIN EACH DEPARTMENT OR NOT
AT ALL. THIS PROCESS LACKS
TRANSPARENCY ACCOUNTABILITY AND
BOTH ARE NEEDED TO FACILITATE
MEANINGFUL CHANGE. EQUITY WILL
WORK REQUIRES LOOKING AT THE
END WE'RE FACING WORK THE STATE
OPERATES LIKE PROCUREMENT
CONTRACTS AND HIRING PRACTICES.
WHILE ENSURING PROGRAMS
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES ADMINISTER
IN THEIR OUTWARD FACING BURKE
ARE EQUITABLE. BY CREATING THE
OFFICE OF RACIAL EQUITY THE
STATE CAN FORMALIZE BEST
PRACTICES LESSONS LEARNED
UTILIZED SHARED RESOURCES TO
MAXIMIZE EFFICIENCY AND PROVIDE
SPACE FOR COMMUNITY DISH. TO
SHARE THEIR LIVED EXPERIENCES.
OF HEALTH POLICY AND PROGRAMS
ARE WORKING TO HELP THEM OR
PERPETUATING HARM. WHEN THE
REDLINING MAPS OF THE NINETEEN
THIRTIES NEAR POOR AIR QUALITY
MAPS AND THE COOK AT NINETEEN
IMPACT MAX OF TWENTY TWENTY THE
DATA IS CLEAR. THE CALL TO
ADDRESS SYSTEMIC RACISM IS NOW
FOR THESE REASONS WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU SANTA MARIA. AT
MODERATOR IF YOU CAN NOW OPEN
UP THE MAIN LINE FOR ANY
ADDITIONAL SUPPORTING OR
OPPOSITION TESTIMONY. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
MAKE A COMMENT SB ONE SEVEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE ENTER ON YOUR
PHONE AT THIS TIME. AMERICA
FIRST TIME I'LL COME FROM LINE
NUMBER FORTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YEAH GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS PRESENT THE
CALIFORNIA NUSES ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT OF S. B. SEVENTEEN
THANK YOU. TOTALING FIFTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
RONALD KOEMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC HEALTH
NETWORKS DEPEND ALSO HERE IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANKS FORTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THE
NUMBER IS TERRIBLE MY NAME IS
ERICA ERICA WITH DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB SEVENTEEN. THANK
SEVENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS WILLIAM BURKE ON BEHALF
OF THE ALL THE CLIENT NAME
APPROACH WHICH CALIFORNIA AND
THE BLACK LEADERSHIP COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT. ONE SEVENTY YEAR LINE
OF THOUGHT OPENED. GOOD
AFTERNOON KELLY BROOKS ON
BEHALF OF THE COUNTY HEALTH
EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA THE COUNTY WELFARE
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION AND THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
PUBLIC HOSPITALS AND HEALTH
SYSTEMS AND STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK SEVENTY FOUR LINE IS OPEN.
OKAY GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
JUSTIN ROWS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER ALSO IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. SEVENTY EIGHT LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS SYLVIA TILLY SHOT WITH
SHALL YOU ORDER ENTRY SCHMELTER
AND LAYING ON IN SUPPORT ON
BEHALF OF THE FOLLOWING CLIENTS
THE CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF CHILD
AND ADOLESCENT PSYCHIATRY THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS FOR THE
CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN
FRANCISCO THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS FOR THE COUNTY OF
SOLANO AND ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF LOS ANGELES MAYOR ERIC
GARCETTI. THANK YOU. THANK
SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
JUSTIN HIGHER WITH A FULL COMBO
IN READERSHIP GROUP AND WE'RE
PROUD TO SUPPORT SB SEVENTEEN
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
DONNA FIGHTS REPRESENTING THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT OF SB
SEVENTEEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MA'AM CHAIR MEMBERS
SUCCESS PROSPECTING WITH PUBLIC
HEALTH ADVOCATE IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANKS. NINETY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS JIM LINDBERG ON BEHALF
OF A FRIEND COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION CALIFORNIA AND
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. FIFTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WHAT'S
YOUR NUMBER THIS IS BRIAN SHOW
UP ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CLIMATE AND AGRICULTURE NETWORK
IN SUPPORT OF SB SEVENTEEN.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
NOT ASSEMBLY ON BEHALF OF THE
CEMETERY- COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND THE SILICON
VALLEY COMMUNITY FOUNDATION
BOTH IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. BY
NINETY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON SURE NUMBERS
MATCH YOU CAN'T YOU WITH UNITED
WAY'S CALIFORNIA INSTRUCTABLE
THANK YOU. EIGHTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS WITH THE DALAI
CAME TO BE HAPPY ABOUT THE
PROJECT CALIFORNIA COULD
SPONSOR THE BILL AND THE REGION
HERE I VOTE ALSO WITH THE WITH
THE SUPPORT OF THE CLEAN WATER
ACTION. COURT ORGANIZATION
THANK YOU. THANK SEVENTY SIX
LINE IS OPEN. SEPT BROWN BOTH
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
PTA SUPPORT SB SEVENTEEN THANK
YOU. THANKS FIFTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO JENNIFER
POTS OF THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT
OF S. B. SEVENTEEN. THANK YOU
TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
ROB ROB SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
SEVENTEEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU
TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON HAVE A BACKUP CALLING
ON BEHALF OF HOW VOICES IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF S. B.
SEVENTEEN THANK YOU. YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. FINALLY WILL BE
HOBBLING THE CALIFORNIA KNOCKS
OF COALITION IN CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL OF COMMUNITY BEHAVIOR
HEALTH AGENCIES IN SUPPORT.
THANKS SIXTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANKS SIXTY SEVEN IT'S
TIME UNIT GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS CALIFORNIA
BABOLAT FOUNDATION SILICON
VALLEY IN SUPPORT. THANK
SEVENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO AND GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS
BEN FOR YOU AND ON BEHALF OF
PREVENTION INSTITUTE IN STRONG
SUPPORT SB SEVENTEEN. THANK YOU.
THANKS SEVENTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS NOW OPEN. THAT AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR NUMBERS ARE YOU
STEINBERG WITH HELP ACCESS IN
SUPPORT OF AT THREE SEVENTEEN
THANK. NINE EIGHTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS AARON
RODRIGUEZ WITH UNION OF
CONCERNED SCIENTISTS AND
SUPPORT THANK YOUNG. THANK
SIXTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS LAUREN
NAVARRO WITH ENVIRONMENTAL
DEFENSE FUND ALSO IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. BY NINETY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
SADDAM THAT'S RAMOS FROM THE UP
THE PUBLIC ADVOCATE WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
SEVENTEEN. THANK YOU. NINE ONE
HUNDRED ON YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON TURN MEMBERS
MADELINE COOPER FROM NIELSEN
MARC MARON BEHALF OF THE COUNTY
OF SAN DIEGO AND LA CARE HEALTH
PLAN BOTH IN SUPPORT OF SB
SEVENTEEN THANK YOU. WE HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANYONE IN
THE HEARING ROOM WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. GOOD AFTERNOON.
SORRY GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS CHRIS MCKINLEY ON
BEHALF OF THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY METROPOLITAN
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY IN OUR
BOARD VOTED TO SUPPORT DOCTOR
PAINS SB SEVENTEEN THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR. THANK YOU. IS
THERE ANYONE WISHING TO TESTIFY
FROM THE REMOTE. VIDEO CENTER.
SCENE NINE I OPEN IT BACK UP TO
THE COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. WHENEVER BURKE HI.
DOCTOR PAN AYE NO LIFE
EXPERIENCE IN DATA HAVE SHOWN
US UNFORTUNATELY THAT WE NEED
TO RAISE EQUITY PLAN AND SO I
THINK YOU FOR YOUR WORK ON THIS
AND WHEN IT IS APPROPRIATE I
WOULD LOVE TO FEEL. INCLUDED AS
A COOPER SO THANK YOU FOR THIS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU YES AND
THANK YOU SENATOR PAN FOR
BRINGING THIS SIDE MEASURE
FORWARD AND FOR YOUR YOUR WORK
ON THIS REALLY IMPORTANT ISSUE
I WITH THAT WE'LL GO AHEAD AND
SECRETARY IF YOU CAN PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. OUT I NEED A
MOTION AND- ALL RIGHT MOTIONS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BURKE AND
SECOND FROM ASSEMBLY. BERMAN
MEDINA MADAM SECRETARY. S. B.
SEVENTEEN THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED AS AMENDED AND RE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS PETRIE-NORRIS I
PETRIE-NORRIS I. PATTERSON
BURKE BURKE AYE GRAY BLACKIE
NOT VOTING LACKEY NOT VOTING
MEDINA MEDINA I BELIEVE FIVE
APPLES AND COLLEAGUES ARE ALL
OPEN THANKS VERY MUCH THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR. SENATOR
STERN WHENEVER YOU ARE READY.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR- CASTRO BY SAYING I KNOW
EVERYONE THINKS THE STAFF BUT
IN THIS CASE- BEEN WORKING
OVERTIME AND PUT YOUR HEAD ON
IT SO I REALLY APPRECIATE IT-
AND I THINK. THE BILL TOGETHER
HERE THAT REALLY FITS THE
MISSION OF THIS COMMITTEE WHICH
IS ABOUT ACCOUNTABILITY- NOT
JUST SORT OF PASSING OPEN ENDED
GOALS- BUT ACTUALLY- HOLDING
THIS ADMINISTRATION AND FINDING
THE KIND OF GOVERNANCE
STRUCTURES THAT WE'RE GONNA GET
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR ALL KINDS OF
PROGRAMS IN THIS CASE WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES- HAPPY TO ACCEPT THAT
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS YOU CAN
FIND THOSE ON PAGE FOR THE
ANALYSIS I KNOW THERE'S A ONE
OTHER LAYER OF DETAIL WE WANTED
TO ADD IN THERE SO WE CAN. WE
CAN ALSO- TALK ABOUT- HOW HOW I
CAN COMMIT HERE TODAY TO
ELEVATING NOT JUST THE ELECTRIC
VEHICLE CHARGING GOALS BUT ALSO
THE HYDROGEN REFUELLING GOALS
IN THIS LEGISLATION- WE RENAMED
THE AUTHORITY DOES SO IT'S NOT
JUST LIKE YOUR VEHICLE THIRTY
TO ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE
AUTHORITY SO OFTEN DEALT WITH
THE TECHNICALITY ISSUE HERE-
INSERTED NOT PUTTING TOO HEAVY
OF A THUMB ON THE SCALE IN
FAVOR OF ONE PARTICULAR
TECHNOLOGY BUT ALSO HOPEFULLY
THIS BILL BY. PUTTING A FIRM
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR INTO THIS AT
THE ALREADY AND HAVING SOMEBODY
THAT THE LEGISLATURE CAN BRING
IN AND HOLD ACCOUNTABLE TO HOW
WERE SHAPING UP TO MEET THESE
GOALS HOPEFULLY THAT'LL
ACTUALLY GIVE US SOME SENSE OF
PROGRESS WE'RE MAKING SO YOU
KNOW WE KNOW WERE WERE
PATROLLING ECONOMY WERE ALSO BE
CLEAN ENERGY ECONOMY TOO BUT WE
DRIVE A LOT AND IF WE'RE GONNA
MAKE THIS BIG TRANSITION TO A
ZERO EMISSIONS FUTURE- IT'S
ONLY GOING TO COME. IN THESE
INCREMENTAL STEPS- WE'VE GOT
SOME AMBITIOUS GOALS FROM THE
GOVERNOR- FOR TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE IN A NUMBER THESE YOUR
MISSION SPACES- THERE'S A LOT
OF MONEY MOVING IN THE SERENE
AS WELL- BUT WE ACTUALLY THINK
WE NEED THIS AUTHORITY TO PUT
ALL TOGETHER AND HOPEFULLY PUT
OUR STATE IN A POSITION WHERE
WE CAN REALLY BE COMPETITIVE I
I'M LOOKING AT THIS BILL AS A
AS AN ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT IN
THE BUSINESS A BUSINESS DRIVER
FEEL NOT SO MUCH AS AN
ENVIRONMENTAL BILL. OF MORE
MANDATE IN ANY WAY BUT TO OFFER
MAJOR AUTOMAKERS- FUELING
COMPANIES- MENU. SHURI'S FOLKS
WANTED. LIVE GET MY FRONT DOOR
SOMEONE THEY CAN WORK WITH I
THINK IT MAKES SENSE TO PUT
THIS WITHIN GO BIZ I THINK THAT
WAS IS THAT THE SMART CHANGING-
ANYWAY I'M I'M EXCITED ABOUT
HOW THIS BILLS OF ALL OF THAT I
THINK WE CAN HOLD THIS WHOLE
COALITION TOGETHER SO. HAPPY TO
GET INTO SOME MORE DETAILS BUT
I THINK THIS BILL WILL PUT
CALIFORNIA SPOT WHERE WE WILL
BE THE MOST POWERFUL NOT JUST
CONSUMER THESE PRODUCTS BUT THE
LARGEST EXPORTER IN THE WHOLE
WORLD OF ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE
TECHNOLOGY AND HOPEFULLY CREATE
A LOT OF JOBS IN THE PROCESS
BECAUSE- I DON'T WANT TO BE
IMPORTING- LET HIM FROM SOUTH
AMERICA. COBALT FROM AFRICA OR-
CARS FROM CHINA SO LET'S TRY TO
DO IT OURSELVES HERE AND
HOPEFULLY THIS GETS US ON TRACK
SO WITH THAT RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR ABOUT. THANK YOU SENATOR
AND I BELIEVE WE'VE GOT ONE
PRIMARY WITNESS IN SUPPORT. OF
MODERATOR IF YOU CAN PLEASE
CONNECT US WITH MICHELLE
KINMAN. RESTRAINING US FROM THE
LOS ANGELES CLEANTECH INCUBATOR.
HELLO YES THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
SENATORS DURING THE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE IT'S A PLEASURE
TO BE HERE WITH YOU TODAY AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR CONSIDERATION
OF THE SPELL WEARING THESE LOS
ANGELES CLEANTECH INCUBATOR IN
THE TRANSPORTATION
ELECTRIFICATION PARTNERSHIP
WHICH IS THE REGIONAL PUBLIC
PRIVATE COLLABORATION TO
ACCELERATE THE PRODUCTION AND
CLIMATE AND AIR POLLUTION BY
THE TIME WORLD ARRIVES FOR THE.
TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT OLYMPIC AND
PARALYMPIC GAMES. THE OTHER
PART THE STATE IN PLACE
REGIONAL BOTH THAT WE BELIEVE
HELP TO. A GLIDE PATH TOWARDS
THE STATE ZERO MISSION VEHICLE
AND INFRASTRUCTURE BALL. AND
WITH PEOPLE THAN MINE BELIEVES
IN PARTNERS. IS THAT THE FORTY
CONTACT TO ENSURE A WHOLE OF
GOVERNMENT APPROACH TO
ACHIEVING AN AFFORDABLE ECONOMY
WIDE TRANSFORMATION ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLE AS. CALIFORNIA
HAS SET OUT TO DO. THE CASHIER
SPEED OF THE DEVICE TRêN IT'S
ON. AT THE SCALE WORK ABOUT.
ANY CHANCE OF SUCCESS WILL BE.
INCREASE WITH THE DATA. AS BEEN
IN MANAGEMENT ARE CONSIDERING
THAT THAT FORTY BE LED BY
ENDING BACK DIRECTOR IN THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF BUSINESS
AND ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT. WILL
BE TECH NEUTRAL AND WE BUILD
THE TUNNEL WORK IN EACH OF THE
AGENCIES INVOLVED IN THE SPACE
TO DO THREE KEY THINGS. FIRST
IT WOULD PROVIDE LEADER
STRATEGIC. AND EXPANDED
PARTNERING TO COMPLEMENT THE
WORK OF STATE AGENCIES
RESPONSIBLE FOR THAT PROGRAM. I
THINK IT WOULD CREATE FUNDING
AND FINANCING TOOL TO SUPPORT
THE VEHICLE INFRASTRUCTURE
DEPLOYMENT EFFORT BRINGING
PRIVATE INVESTMENT TO THE TABLE.
AND FINALLY THE SEVEN FORTY
WOULD PRIORITIZE EQUITY ACROSS
ALL INVESTMENT IMPLEMENTATION
AND DEPLOYMENT. AS WELL AS DR
FOR BLACK ECONOMIC AND
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM.
IMPORTANT AS WITH YOUR MISSION
TRANSITION REQUIRES SOMEONE WHO
IS RESPONSIBLE AND ACCOUNTABLE
TO THE GOVERNOR LEGISLATURE AND
PEOPLE CALIFORNIA FOR MAKING IT
HAPPEN. AND MOST EFFICIENT WAY
POSSIBLE. PROUDLY JOINED BY
MORE THAN EIGHTY ORGANIZATIONS
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
INCLUDING LOCAL GOVERNMENT
INDUSTRY LEADERS STARTUP
ENVIRONMENTS ORGANIZATIONS
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE GROUPS
PUBLIC HEALTH LABOR ACADEMIA
AND MORE AND WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE THAT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU I IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE HEARING ROOM
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
SEEN ON OUR MODERATOR HI CAN
YOU OPEN UP THE LINES FOR
ANYONE WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SB. FIVE FIVE ONE.
PLEASE ENTER A MENTOR SHOW
SUPPORT FOR SB FIVE FIVE ONE
PLEASE PRESS ONE TO ENTER ON
YOUR TOUCH TONE PHONE. OUR
FIRST TIME- COMPROMISED NUMBER
FORTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
CAPPING LANCE REPRESENTING OUR
PLUGIN AMERICA CONSUMER GROUP
IS STRONG SUPPORT AND THANK
DEFENDER FOR BRINGING THAT
STUFF FORWARD. THANK YOU.
MEXICO LINE FIFTY TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON DANIEL
BROUGHT ON BEHALF OF SIERRA
CLUB CALIFORNIA SUPPORT THANK
YOU. FIND ONE HUNDRED AND FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
DONNA THANKS FOR VISITING THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IS SUPPORTED SB
FIVE FIFTY ONE THANK YOU. FIND
A BEER LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YOU TO TAKE PHONE
OPPOSITION TO SB SEVENTEEN YOU
HAD CALIFORNIANS THE WAITING ON
THE LINE AND YOU DID NOT TAKE
PHONE OPPOSITION TO SB
SEVENTEEN SO SORRY MA'AM HI
MA'AM WE I SPECIFICALLY SAID IF
THERE IS ANYONE WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN EITHER SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. I THINK YOU HAVE
MULTIPLE PEOPLE WHO DID NOT GET
RUN THROUGH OUR YOUR PHONE'S
BROKEN BECAUSE WE'RE BEGINNING
TO WONDER. THANK YOU MA'AM WILL
REGISTER YOUR OPPOSITION TO SB
SEVENTEEN. PEOPLE. EIGHT THE
VAGARIES OF OURS SIX VIRTUAL
REALITY AND ERIC MOVING BACK TO
SB FIVE FIVE ONE. I WE'RE
TAKING SUPPORT TESTIMONY ON SB.
FIVE FIVE ONE. NINE SIXTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON HELLO TRODDEN ON
BEHALF OF AN L. NORTH AMERICA
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. NINE ONE
HUNDRED AND FIVE YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
BALKANS OFFICE ON THE UP THE
CITIES OF ELK GROVE AND
THOUSAND OAKS IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THANK SIXTY ONE YOUR LINE
IS NOW OPEN. HELLO WE'LL BRING
HER ON BEHALF OF THREE FIFTY
SACRAMENTO IN SUPPORT. THANK
SIXTY FOR YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
THANK SIXTY FOUR LINE IS OPEN.
SOME OF THE UNDERLYING SIXTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON KATHY SHAPER SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY CLIMATE REALITY
PROJECT IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
FIFTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
CAPTAIN BORG WITH SO CAL EDISON
IN SUPPORT. THANK SEVENTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON CAMMY KERR WITH NEXT
GEN CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. NINE NINETY FOR YOUR LINE
IS NOW OPEN. NINE NINE FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE INCLUDE
YOUR PHONE. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS
IS LINDA CLEVELAND WATCH CLEAN
AIR AND ENERGY COMMITTEE
STAKEHOLDER OF WHAT. WE ARE
STRONG SUPPORTER SB FIVE FIVE
ONE THANK YOU. THANK SIXTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS ARIEL LOPEZ
ON BEHALF OF LOS ANGELES
BUSINESS COUNCIL AND STRONG
SUPPORT AT THE FIVE FIVE ONE
THANK YOU. NINE EIGHTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AFTERNOON
STOP MEREKA AND WE'RE IN FRONT
WORK. NINE ONE HUNDRED AND
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NOT
INSURED MEMBERS WILL BE ASKED
TO LEAVE THE SHOP ON THE HALF
OF THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES AND
ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE BEST TO
BEGIN WITH KAREN- IS GOING. TO
GET A SIMILAR FATE THANK YOU.
NO ADDITIONAL COMMENT THANK YOU
AT THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU AT MODERATOR IS THERE
ANYONE WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT FROM OUR REMOTE VIDEO.
CENTER AND ARE YOU HERE IN
SUPPORT. OKAY MOVING ON TO
OPPOSITION TESTIMONY IS THERE
ANYONE. IN THE HEARING ROOM
MACHINE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. GOOD MORNING KAREN
MEMBERS I'D TERESA COOK ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
HYDROGEN COALITION
UNFORTUNATELY I STILL OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED I WITH HE NEVER
GUARD TO THE AMENDMENTS THAT.
HAVE BEEN AGREED TO AND
RECOMMENDED THEM IN THE IN THE
ANALYSIS- WE APPRECIATE THE
COMMITTEE'S WORK PARTICULARLY
JESSE IN THE CHAIR FOR TRYING
TO SEEK- MORE TECHNOLOGY
NEUTRAL PATHWAY BUT
UNFORTUNATELY UNTIL HYDROGEN.
BILL AND IT SHOULD BE MORE
TECHNOLOGY INCLUSIVE AND I
THINK IF WE ARE GOING TO CREATE
AN ENTIRELY NEW STATE ENTITY
THAT IS CHARGED WITH ENSURING
THAT WE MEET OUR ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLE CALLS THAT DIRECTION
NEEDS TO BE GIVEN TO THIS
ENTITY TO ENSURE THAT THE
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT IS
NECESSARY TO SUPPORT THE ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLE GOALS. IS IN
PLACE AND NOT AS CHARGING AND
HYDROGEN REFUELLING SO TO THAT
END WE WOULD REALLY ENCOURAGE
THE COMMITTEE- TOO HIGH YOU
KNOW HOW- PUSH FOR THOSE
AMENDMENTS THANK YA. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS SERVICE I'M IN AUSTIN
FOR THE CALIFORNIA HYDROGEN
BUSINESS COUNCIL WHERE HER
UNFORTUNATELY IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL WE HAVE THE SAME
EXACT CONCERNS AS THE
CALIFORNIA HYDROGEN COLLISION
JUST SPOKE TO BY. THERESA WE'RE
GOING TO MEET THESE GOALS FOR
HAVING ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES
ON THE ROAD WE REALLY DO NEED
THE HYDROGEN REFUELLING
INFRASTRUCTURE I MYSELF AM A
FUEL CELL ELECTRIC VEHICLE
OWNER I DROVE HERE TO THE
CAPITAL TODAY AND THE
INFRASTRUCTURE IS VERY MUCH
NEEDED I WOULD NOW IS THE TIME
FOR CALIFORNIA TO LEAD. IN
BUSINESS OPPORTUNITIES FOR
HYDROGEN REFUELLING AND WE
CAN'T LEAVE OUT AN ENTIRE
SECTOR OF ELECTRIC VEHICLES
FROM THIS BILL SO WE ARE IN
OPPOSITION OF HOW THE BILL
STANDS WITH THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS I AM VERY
APPRECIATIVE OF THE DISCUSSIONS
AND THE WORK THAT HAS BEEN HAD
BY THIS COMMITTEE IN THE
COMMITTEE CONSULTANTS AND THE
AUTHOR'S OFFICE ON THIS BILL.
UNFORTUNATELY WE'RE JUST NOT
THERE YET- ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES MEAN ALL ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES AND IF THIS ENTITY IS
GOING TO BE OVERSEEN GERMAN
VEHICLES WE CANNOT LEAVE OUT
HYDROGEN FUEL CELL ELECTRIC
VEHICLES SORRY TO MEET THESE
GOALS REALLY LOVE TO SEE THOSE
MOMENTS PUT IN PLACE. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU OUR
MODERATOR IS THERE ANYONE I ON
THE PHONE WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB. FIVE FIVE
ONE. FOR A POSITION TO SB FIVE
FIVE ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
THEY'RE ON YOUR TOUCH TONE
PHONE. FIRST GO TO LINE ONE
HUNDRED AND TEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THERE
STEVEN MINUTES ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN LUNG ASSOCIATION- AND
ARE YOU CALLING IN REGARD TO SB
FIVE FIVE ONE IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL I APOLOGIZE TRAVESTY
TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES THERE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. WHAT A LINE
SIXTY FOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. AS
PART OF OUR WORK ENVIRONMENTAL
DEFENSE FUND AND ALSO IN
SUPPORT I DIDN'T GET CALLED ON
IN THE LAST. I'M STILL SPEAKING
ARMY THIS TIME INSTRUCTOR FOR
THANK YOU. I KNOW ONE HUNDRED
AND THREE LINE IS NOW OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON THAT I ALSO
TRYING TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT DURING THE LAST-
OPPORTUNITY BUT- I DIDN'T GET A
NUMBER OF SITES OUT I DIDN'T
TIDY SET FOR DIRECT POLICY IT
AMPLY POWER AND WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU IT SO IT'S LIKE WE
MIGHT BE HAVING A FEW MINOR
DIFFICULTIES SO IF YOU'RE ON
THE LINE IN SUPPORT. NO NEED TO
EXPLAIN JUST GO AHEAD AND
REGISTER YOUR SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. RIGHT NOW. SB. FIVE
FIVE ONE. NINE FIFTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. MY NAME IS
THEIR AG IN THE LATE SINCE I
DIDN'T GET A CHANCE TO-
PROPOSED BILL SB SEVENTEEN I'D
LIKE TO REGISTER THAT RIGHT NOW
THE CRITICAL APPLICATIONS AND
THAT'S- NOT THE THING THANK YOU
THANK YOU. ONE MOMENT PLEASE
ONLY PROVIDE A LINE NUMBER TO
THE NEXT COMMENTER. FREESTYLE.
ALL RIGHT SOUNDS LIKE WE DON'T
HAVE ANYONE ELSE IN THE LINES
ANYONE IN THE REMOTE VIDEO
TESTIMONY FACT. THAT BOB AND I
WILL JUST SAY TO FOLKS WHO ARE-
WATCHING OR LISTENING FROM HOME
AND HAVE BEEN TRYING TO ENGAGE
I WE CERTAINLY. TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT VERY SERIOUSLY AND TAKE
YOUR INPUT VERY SERIOUSLY SO DO
APOLOGIZE FOR ANY TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTIES AND DEATH. PLEASE
WEIGH IN. WHEN NOW ON WHATEVER%
YOU WHATEVER IT MIGHT BE OPEN
ALL RIGHT MOVING ADD TO THAT A
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
BURKE I JUST WANT TO THINK THAT.
TO THE CENTER'S POINT I WANT TO
THANK YOUR STAFF I KNOW THIS
WAS A LOT OF WORK AND SOME OF
IT AT THE LAST MINUTE SO I WANT
TO THANK YOU I WANT TO THANK
THE SENATOR FOR BEING OPEN- TO
THIS ISSUE OBVIOUSLY FOR MY
DISTRICT- TECHNIQUE TECHNOLOGY
NEUTRAL SUPER IMPORTANT-
HYDROGEN IS JUST A MORE
AFFORDABLE AT THIS TIME
OPPORTUNITY FOR PEOPLE IN MY
DISTRICT MORE FLEXIBLE AND SO
MAKING SURE THAT. EVERY OPTION
IS INCLUDED IN ON THE TABLE IS
REALLY IMPORTANT SO I
APPRECIATE THE CHAIR I
APPRECIATE THE STAFF AND I
APPRECIATE THE SENATOR FOR
WORKING THIS OUT AND KIND OF
MOVING. THE AMENDMENTS PASS
WHERE WE WHAT WE HAVE NOW AND-
AND THE DIRECTION THAT MAKES
THAT MARKS AT SCHOOL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU HI MISTER GRAY. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR NICE TO SEE YOU
SENATOR- IN THE ANALYSIS IS
SCISSORS TWENTY NINE SEPARATE
STATE AGENCIES THAT PLAY A LEAD
OR SUPPORTING ROLE IN THIS
EFFORT RIGHT. DO I
MISUNDERSTAND THE BILL IF I
WERE TO MAKE THE STATEMENT THAT
AFTER PASSED IN THIS BILL WILL
NOT HAVE THIRTY STATE AGENCIES
OR- ORGANIZATIONS PLAYING A
ROLE- I DON'T THINK YOU SHOULD
CRISTINA AGENCY. I THINK THE
WAY THE WAY FOR. YOU TO OFFICES
ENGAGE WITH ADDS ANOTHER ENTITY
IT DOESN'T REDUCE ANY OF THOSE
TWENTY NINE IS KIND OF WHAT I'M
DRIVING AT THAT DOES NOT NOT
LESS THAN TWENTY NINE CORRECT.
AND SO. YOU KNOW IN YOUR
OPENING STATEMENT POINT IS THAT
THIS BILLS. IN THE SPIRIT OF
KINDNESS COMMITTEE AN ACCOUNT
ON SO ON AND- ALTHOUGH I
APPLAUD YOUR- GENERAL EFFORT ON
TRYING TO REALLY PUSH- WITH THE
DRAMATIC EFFORT FOR
ELECTRIFICATION. YOU KNOW OF
OUR TRANSPORTATION. SECTOR HERE
AND I CAN SAY THAT I REPRESENT
AS YOU KNOW YOU'VE BEEN TO MY
DISTRICT I REPRESENT A DISTRICT
IN THE HEART OF CALIFORNIA WE
HAVE THE NINETY NINE- AS WELL
AS THE- FIVE RUNNING. BOTH
THROUGH MY DISTRICT SO PEOPLE
FROM SAM CISCO IN LA REGULARLY
DRIVE THROUGH AND LEAVE THEIR
POLLUTION BEHIND- SO WE'RE
SENSITIVE TO THIS YOU KNOW WE
ARE PUSHING TO GET. A CLEAN
HIGH SPEED RAIL INTO THE VALLEY
ALTHOUGH THERE ARE SOME OF OUR
COLLEAGUES FROM LA WHO. SEEM TO
WANT TO REPLACE THAT WITH
DIESEL TRAINS AND POLLUTION
AGAIN- THAT'S NOT WHAT YOU'RE
DOING HERE YOU'RE TRYING TO
PUSH FOR A CLEAN- VEHICLE FORCE
OUT THERE I JUST FEEL LIKE I
WOULD LOVE TO. WORK ON THE BILL
WITH THE WORK ON THIS BILL OR
OR ANOTHER EFFORT TO REALLY
REDUCE THE TWENTY IT'S ABSURD
THE POOREST TWENTY NINE
AGENCIES DOING DUPLICATIVE
THANKS RIGHT AND THAT'S ACROSS.
THE CROSS GOVERNMENT FRANKLY
HERE IN CALIFORNIA BECAUSE THE
LEGISLATURE PARTICULARLY IN THE
LAST TWENTY YEARS. RATHER THAN
DIGGING IN AND DEAL WITH THESE
ISSUES WE LOVE TO KIND OF
PONTIFICATE MAKE A BIG
STATEMENT START A NEW AGENCY
AND KICK SOME JOB OUT THAT THE
NEVER GETS DONE THE WE COME
BACK AND CLEAN IT UP LATER AND-
IT'S CODES PERPETUAL CYCLE
RIGHT NOW. AND I FEEL LIKE
DESPITE YOUR GOOD INTENTIONS
WERE WALKING DOWN THAT ROAD YET
AGAIN WITH THIS BILL- WOULD YOU
BE WILLING TO. I DON'T KNOW
PARK THE BILL AND DIG INTO IT
WITH THE COMMITTEE AND SEE IF
WE COULD FIGURE OUT A WAY TO
REDUCE. THOSE TWENTY NINE
AGENCIES OR MOVE SOME OF THE
SUPPORTER EVEN CENTRALIZED
AUTHORITY ONE PLACE WHICH MAKES
TONS OF SENSE TO ME RIGHT- IS
THAT SOME YOU CONSIDERED YOU
FEEL LIKE YOUR- TOO FAR DOWN
THE LINE HERE. THE CHALLENGE I
HAVE IS SO LET'S JUST TALK
THROUGH THE BRIEF A FEW OF THE
AGENCY SO TAKE LIKE HYSTERIA
RESOURCES BOARD AND THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION. I DON'T
KNOW IF YOU'RE INTERFACING WITH
CITY ELECTRIC SECTOR THE GAS
SECTOR AND YOU'RE TRYING TO
INTERCONNECT THE HYDROGEN
FUELING STATION OR A- AND YOU
KNOW OUR ELECTRIC VEHICLE
CHARGING STATION. YOU GOTTA GO
THROUGH BOTH THE LOCAL LAND USE
THIRTY THAN PVC. I DON'T KNOW
QUITE HOW IT STREAMLINED OR
LIKE WHAT WHERE WE ARE WE TO
LIMIT RIGHT BECAUSE THE
AIRPORTS DRIVING IT ON THE AIR
SIDE THEN THERE'S THE LOCAL
DISTRICTS- MEAN ONE THING. I
COULD OFFER MAYBE IT DOESN'T
SATISFY YOU BUT THERE'S
LANGUAGE IN HERE THE TALKS
ABOUT SORT OF COORDINATING
VARIOUS EFFORTS ACROSS RELEVANT
STATE AGENCIES TO ENSURE THEY
ARE NOT ENACTING RULES OR
REGULATIONS THAT ARE IN
CONFLICT WITH ONE ANOTHER. WHAT
CAN WE E
ALSO SAYS I MEAN IT TALKS ABOUT
STREAMLINING TO BUT- IS THERE
SOME WAY. TO BOLSTER THIS
POSITION AND GO BEYOND
COORDINATION MAYBE MAKING- I'M
THINKING OUT LOUD HERE BUT JUST
YOU KNOW MAKING RECOMMENDATIONS
ABOUT IT- WE'RE SAYING NOT IN
CONFLICT WE COULD ALSO TALK
ABOUT DUPLICATION. THERE
POTENTIALLY I'M I'M RETICENT TO
JUST SAY LET'S PUT THIS ON HOLD
BECAUSE THERE'S SO MUCH FEDERAL
AND STATE MONEY MOVING I
HONESTLY THINK WE NEED THIS NOW
I'D LIKE I'M I DON'T I JUST
KICK IT TO THE SPAGHETTI SOUP
THAT IT CURRENTLY IS SO. I
THINK WE NEED THIS NOW BUT A
I'M OPEN TO. YEAH WHAT ELSE
WOULD I WOULD JUST AND I WOULD
JUST ADD SO MISTER I THINK IT
WAS EVER FOR YOUR THOUGHTFUL
COMMENTS I CERTAINLY WHEN I
FIRST SAW THIS BUT I THINK THAT
MAGIC CONSULTANT ACIDIFIED TO
IT IS FOR THE NASCAR LOCAL OF
INVOLVED AGENCIES. AND AGRO
BUSINESS ACTUALLY GONE THROUGH
AN EXERCISE OF OUTLINING THAT
THE PIECE OF THE PUZZLE THAT
EACH OF THOSE AGENCIES PLAY I
DO THINK THERE PROBABLY IS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR SOME SOME
STREAMLINING AND SOME
RATIONALIZATION BEYOND THIS.
BUT I WOULD ALSO SAY THAT
HAVING. AN AUTHORITY THAT IS
THEN RESPONSIBLE FOR CHEATING
THE SCHOOLS MAKES IT THAT CAN
BE THE PERSON WE GO TO AND SAY.
HEY ONE OF YOUR DELIVERABLES IS
GOING TO BE STREAMLINING
RATIONALIZING AND GETTING SOME
OF THESE SUPERFLUOUS FOLKS OUT
TO THE EXTENT THAT. THAT THERE
ARE SUPERFLUOUS PLAYERS SO I'M
I CERTAINLY WOULD IMAGINE THAT
SENATOR STERN WOULD WELCOME
YOUR- ENGAGEMENT AND INPUT ON
THAT AS THIS IS MOVING. FROM
THIS COMMITTEE IN TWO I WILL BE
HEARD BY THE TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE- CENTER RETURN HAS
EXPRESSED A WILLINGNESS TO
TAKES AMENDMENTS ON THE
TECHNICALITY SIDE OF THINGS SO.
TO THE EXTENT THAT THAT YOU
WOULD LIKE TO ENGAGE FURTHER
BEFORE. THIS BECOMES FINAL
PRODUCT I'M SURE HE'D WELCOME
THAT WELL I APPRECIATE THAT
MADAM CHAIR AND- YOU KNOW WITH
ALL DUE RESPECT TO
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE. I
BELIEVE THE CHAIR THE
TRANSPORTATION IS ONE OF THE
PEOPLE TRYING TO PUT DIESEL
TRAINS IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
SO I WOULD JUST ASSUME TRUST
CHAIR THIS COMMITTEE IF THE
STAY ON TOPIC ON TOPIC WAS A
GREAT. ENGAGE IN THE EFFORT.
WHAT WHAT WHAT I WILL SAY
CENTER NOT APPRECIATE- YOU KNOW
YOUR THOUGHTFUL RESPONSE IN THE
SENSE TO BE ABLE TO WORK WITH
ME. IS MAYBE WE SHOULD
CONSIDER- A SUNSET DATE. ON
THIS UNDER AFTER LIKE THIS SO
THAT THERE'S A MANDATED. REVIEW
BECAUSE IN ESSENCE WHEN YOU ASK
THE- KIM WHAT WHEN YOU HAS THIS
NEW. ENTITY TO ELIMINATE
DUPLICATIVE. AGENCY EFFORTS
THAT'S ESSENTIALLY ASKING THIS
ENTITY TO DO OUR JOB RIGHT
BECAUSE WHERE THE LEGISLATURE
IT'S OUR JOB TO DO THE
OVERSIGHT OF YOU KNOW WHO'S GOT
WHAT AUTHORITY AND- AND SO ON.
BUT IF YOU HAD A SON TODAY YOU
CAN LOOK AT HOW THIS WORKS HOW
EFFECTIVE ARE THEY HAVEN'T COME
BACK AND YOU KNOW BEFORE THE
LEGISLATURE IT SOMETIME- TO THE
CHAIRS POINT I'M CERTAINLY NOT
GOING TO ASK YOU TO. TAKE THAT
AMENDMENT HERE TODAY. SHE WAS
TO WORK ON IT WE CAN TALK SOME
MORE. ABOUT IT I MAY OR MAY NOT
IT DOES AS THE BILL IS AND
PRINT CURRENTLY AT SUNSET ON
JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
NINE WHICH- YOU KNOW. YOU CAN
DEBATE WHETHER OR NOT THAT'S A-
APPROPRIATE TIME PRESENT BUT
THERE IS A SENSE THAT IN THE
BOOK. I GUESS WHAT. FOR
APPOINTMENT VENTURA I THINK A
SUNSET DATE MAYBE A LITTLE.
SOONER THAN TWENTY TWENTY NINE
MIGHT BE APPROPRIATE BECAUSE
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT EFFORT.
OUR BEGIN ON PROBABLY GONNA.
LAY OFF TODAY- IT'LL KEEP
DIALOGUING WITH YOU AND I SAID
PRESHEAF WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
DO I THINK. IT'S A VALIANT
EFFORT- IT JUST CONCERNS ME WE-
HAVE A REALLY POOR HISTORY
LEGISLATURE PUNTING. OUT TO
BUREAUCRACY YOU KNOW. AND I
THINK THAT'S A DANGEROUS THING
WITHOUT THE APPROPRIATE
MEASURES IN PLACE TO. MAKE SURE
TO YOUR POINT WHERE YOU STARTED
WITH YOUR PRESENTATION AT ITS
ACCOUNTABLE SO THANKS FOR YOUR
EFFORT APPRECIATE- YOU
ENTERTAINING- SOME I THOUGHT.
THANK YOU AND I AM COMMITTED
HOPE WE CAN EARN YOUR VOTE. IF
THIS GETS TO THE FLOOR- STARTED
LOOK AT SUNSET ACCOUNTABILITY
THE REPORTING FUNCTION HELLO WE
CAN. HAPPY TO THINK THAT
THROUGH AS WE MOVE IF WE GET TO
MOVE FORWARD HERE. THANKS ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU SENATOR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RODRIGUEZ
YOU'RE JUST ONE OF THE A LOT OF
MY COMMENTS WITH OF OPPOSITION
REGARDING HOW TO GET. MY
DIFFICULT SEVERAL HUNDRED
FACILITIES WILL BE IMPACTED BY
A BILL LIKE THIS WE DON'T
INCLUDE THEM SO. LIKE YOU'RE
LOOKING TO ADDRESS DOESN'T YES
MAYBE HOPEFULLY DO IT AND- I
RESERVE MY RIGHT BEFORE BUT- AS
A- TRYING TO HELP YOU ALONG THE
OAKLAND SUPPORT RIGHT NOW. WHEN
WE GET RESERVE MY RIGHT FOR THE
PEOPLE THANKS THANK YOU CANNOT
AND ASSEMBLY. MEMBER MEDINA.
STERN TENORS ALL RIGHT
REPRESENT RIVERSIDE. THE OF THE
NINETY ONE FREEWAY ALSO OF
TRAFFIC. US A VERY CONCERNED-
WITH THE YOU KNOW THE GOALS OF
YOUR BILL- BUT I ALSO SHARE MY
OTHER COLLEAGUES- CONCERNED
ABOUT- TECH. NEUTRALITY AND I
SAID ON THE- TRANSPORTATION.
COMMITTEE SO I WILL BE SEEING
THIS BILL AGAIN- MIGHT YOU
SHARE A LITTLE BIT MORE OF WHAT
KIND OF TECHNICALITY.
ATTENDANCE POLICY WHEN YOU'RE
THE BILL COMES TO. THE
TRANSPORTATION. AND YES AND I
AND I WOULD I WOULD I WANTED.
TO FOR IF THE CHAIR WANTS TO
COMMENT ON IT BUT WHAT WHAT WE
HAD DISCUSSED IS- THERE'S A-
THE BILL ENUMERATES A AN
EXECUTIVE ORDER GOAL AROUND
CHARGING STE CHARGING STATIONS
SINCE TWENTY FIFTY THOUSAND
CHARGING STATION BUT IT DOESN'T
ENUMERATE. ANY OF THE STATE'S
HYDROGEN FUELING STATION CALLS
RIGHT SO LET'S GET EXPLICIT
ABOUT THOSE AND ADD THOSE IN
HERE TOO- THE SAKE LIKE WHAT IT
I THINK IT'S- THEIRS TO IT'S A
TWO HUNDRED STATION GOAL BY
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE I THINK IS.
WHAT WE SAW ON THE AMENDMENTS
FROM THE OPPOSITION. HAPPY TO
ADD THAT IT. THE OTHER PIECES
JUST TRYING TO MAKE SURE THAT
WHERE IF THE BILL IS TALKING
ABOUT- CHARGING BUT NOT
NECESSARILY REFUELLING. RIGHT
LIKE GETTING THE LANGUAGE RIGHT
SO THAT WE'RE NOT DOING ANY
WE'RE NOT UNDER CUTTING AND
ANALYSIS SAY OF LIKE HOW TO
INNER INTER CONNECTING EEVEE
CHARGER BECAUSE THAT'S GONNA BE
DIFFERENT PROCESS THAN
STREAMLINING A HYDROGEN FUELING
STATION BUT JUST THAT. WE'VE
GOT SORT OF COROLLARY PIECES TO
DEAL WITH THE HYDROGEN SIDE OF
IT SO THE LANGUAGE OF THE
OPPOSITION AND THE NUMBER AND
ALL THAT AND ALL THAT YES THE
NUMBER WRITER CHEN WILL BE
INCLUDED. YES YES THE NUMBER. I
HAVEN'T SEEN ALL THE- DETAILS
OF THE REST OF IT LIKE. LINE BY
LINE YOU KNOW. GOING THROUGH
AND EVERY TIME IT SAYS THE WORD
LIKE. STREAMLINING ELECTRIC
UTILITY INTERCONNECTION AND
INTERNALIZATION PROCESS I DON'T
KNOW HOW YOU DO THAT FOR
HYDROGEN BUT- WANTED FIGURE
THAT LIKE IF WE NEED TO DO
WHAT'S- WE MAY NOT STRIKE THAT
I THINK THERE IS A PROPOSAL IS
SAFE. JUST STRIKE THAT PHRASE
MAYBE WE ADD A SECOND PROVISION
SAY WE ALSO WANT TO STREAMLINE
INTERCONNECTION PROCESS FOR.
HYDROGEN REFUELLING SOIT'S NOT
ALL IN THE AMENDS THERE MAY BE
OTHER STUFF WE'VE GOT TO DO TO
LAND THAT. WE'RE IN A BIT OF A
TIME CRUNCH THAT'S THE HARD
THING HERE SO I DON'T KNOW HOW
TO LAND ALL THAT DETAIL HERE
TODAY. DEFINITELY THE GOAL.
DEFINITELY CONFORMITY AROUND
TECHNICALITY JUST EXACTLY WHAT
THOSE DETAILS ARE KIND OF I
DON'T WANT TO GET AHEAD OF THE
CHAIR OR AND- SO. WELL WITH
YOUR COMMITMENT THAT YES IT
WILL BE HAVING A NEUTRAL AND
YES USING THE LEVERAGE OF THE
OPPOSITION. YEAH CAN SUPPORT
THE BILL YEAH THANK YOU FOR
THAT SIGNAL IS A MAN OF COURSE
NO THANK YOU FOR THE COMMENT
AND- I SPOKE TO MISS COOK
ACTUALLY BEFORE THIS HEARING
AND I THINK. WE'RE MAKING
PROGRESS HERE SO THANKS FOR
WAITING AND- YEAH WE DON'T
THINK THAT. WITH WANT UNDER
ANYTHING THAT IN THE HYDROGEN
FUELING SPACE WITH THIS AND WE
DON'T WANT TO SAY CALIFORNIA IS
NOT COMMITTED TO THAT ANYMORE
SO WE'VE GOT A WE'VE GOT GOALS
FROM THE IDEA. ANYWAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND
YES SIR THANK YOU SENATOR I
THINK BOTH FOR. YOUR COMMITMENT
TO ENSURING WE'RE ACTUALLY
MAKING PROGRESS TOWARDS OUR- AS
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE COLES I
THINK IS YOU SAID IN YOUR
OPENING COMMENTS IT'S VERY EASY
FOR US AS THE LEGISLATURE. TO
COME UP WITH. IN A BIG AND BOLD
GOALS SEND OUT A BUNCH OF PRESS
RELEASES AND PASSED PAT
OURSELVES ON THE BACK FOR
SOLVING A PROBLEM WE HAVEN'T.
ACTUALLY DONE NOTHING. I AND SO
I THINK PUTTING IN PLACE.
ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES TO
ENSURE THAT ARE ACTUALLY MAKING
PROGRESS ON THIS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT GOAL. IS CRITICAL.
AND I ALSO APPRECIATE THAT YOUR
COMMITMENT TO TECHNICALITY. I
DO THINK SOME OF THE- REMAINING
DETAIL AND THE LANGUAGE. THANK
IS. FRANKLY THE RESULT OF THE
FACT THAT TO. A LEAD COUNSEL
FOR EXAMPLE IN THEIR DRAFT WHEN
THEY'RE DRAFTING LANGUAGE THE
WORD CHARGING. DOES NOT SEEM TO
BE A LOADED WORD. LECTURE IN
KIND OF AN INDUSTRY EXPERT SO
I. HAD NO THAT WE'VE TALKED
ABOUT THIS AND I'VE TALKED
ABOUT THIS WITH THE NUMBER OF
FOLKS ON THE COMMITTEE. AND WE
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMITMENT TO
ENSURING THAT THIS IS ADDRESSED
AND- YEAH I THINK. WE CERTAINLY
DO RESERVE THE RIGHT TO CALL
BACK. ABSOLUTELY SO WITH THAT I
ANYTHING FURTHER IN- TO PUSHY
THE ENGAGEMENT AND THE C. U. N.
TRANSPORTATION HOPEFULLY NEXT
WEEK AND WANT TO WIN THIS THING
BEFORE THE FLOOR AND MAYBE EVEN
EARNED MY GOOD FRIEND FROM
CENTRAL VALLEY SUPPORTS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL.
POPULOUS THANK YOU I MADAM
SECRETARY SO WE NEED A MOTION
AND A SECOND. THANK YOU. YEAH
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU AT MOTION
FROM IS BURKE SECOND FROM MR
MEDINA. S. B. FIVE FIVE ONE THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED AS AMENDED
AND RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE
ON TRANSPORTATION.
PETRIE-NORRIS HI PETRIE-NORRIS
I. PATTERSON BURKE. BURKE AYE
GRAY. LACKING LACKEY I MEDINA
MEDINA I RODRIGUEZ. RODRIGUEZ I
ALL RIGHT FIVE ZERO THAT BELL
IS OUT AND WILL LEAVE THE ROLE
IF AND FOR OTHERS TO ADD ON AND
THAT THANK YOU SENATOR. YOU
NUMBER OF PEOPLE. HEY ALL HELLO.
HELLO SENATOR LIMóN HI MADAM
CHAIR HELLO MEMBERS. THE BILL.
SO I WANT TO THANK YOU AND I
WANT TO START BY ACCEPTING I
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS AND
ESSENCE THERE'S A MOTION AND A
SECOND I AM HAPPY TO KEEP GOING
OR JUST KIND OF THAT THAT WE
CAN START WITH QUESTIONS. ALL
RIGHT. I KNOW THE GREEN CARPET
WAYS. LET'S SEE I THINK WE'VE
GOT AT TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES
WHO ARE HERE TO TESTIFY INSUPPORT SO WE WILL MAKE SURE
THAT WE GET THOSE FOLKS ON THE
LINE MODERATOR IF YOU CAN
PLEASE CONNECT US WITH CRISTINA
HERNANDEZ. AYE FROM THE HOPE
LEADERSHIP INSTITUTE OF ORANGE
COUNTY. BOTH WITNESSED LANES
ARE OPEN. HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEMBER ID
THIRTY NINE MILLION MEMBERS MY
NAME IS CRISTINA HERNANDEZ
CALLING IN FROM ORANGE COUNTY
AND IN A NUMBER OF THE HISPANIC
ORGANIZED BOOK MEDICAL ACQUIRED
QUALITY I HOPE WE ARE
SIGNIFICANT OPEN THE NONPROFIT
NONPARTISAN ORGANIZATION
COMMITTED TO ENSURING THE
POLITICAL AND ECONOMIC PARITY
OF LOOKING AT THE LEADERSHIP
ADVOCACY AND EDUCATION PROVIDES.
THE OPPORTUNITY THE STATUS OF
WOMEN. AT THE COLLEGE
EVERYTHING MYSELF EVERY DAY I
WORK HARD FOR EACH OTHER IT IS
UNDERSTAND THEY HAVE A VOICE
OKAY MAKE A DIFFERENCE IN THE
NINETEEN WILL BE THAT THEY ARE
PART OF. MY STUDENTS ARE
ENCOURAGED TO VOTE COULD BE
INFORMED. AND ENGAGED IN THE
MARKET GET MULTIPLE LEVELS.
YEAH AFTER SPENDING VERY
ENCOURAGING STUDENTS TO BE
ACTIVE BUT IT'S AN- EVEN I HAD
A LIMITED UNDERSTANDING. WHY
COMMISSION THE BOARD. THAT IS.
UNTIL I BECAME INVOLVED WITH
HELP. THE PROCESS GIVEN A TRIAL.
THE NOT WANT TO THE- CALIFORNIA.
AND WE HAVE NO. DEMOCRATIC DATA
TO DEMONSTRATE THAT THE BOY
THINKING. INFLUENCING IMPORTANT
POLICIES REPRESENTED DIVERSITY
OF OUR STATE. SB SEVEN RGO AS A
NECESSITY BECAUSE IT WOULD
REQUIRE AN ANNUAL REPORT. IS
QUOTING A DEMOGRAPHIC DATA OF
ALL GOOD METRO TWENTY. THE
BOARD AND COMMISSIONS OF THE
STATE. THAT'S WHAT PACKAGE SB
NEXT YEAR WOULD BE THE FIRST
STEP IN ENSURING THAT ALL
CALIFORNIANS HAVE A VOICE IN
STATE GOVERNMENT. IN A CONTEXT
WHERE CURRENTLY AND WHAT PUBLIC
ANXIETY OVER DEMOCRACY BEING
ABLE TO FEEDBACK A GOVERNMENT
REPRESENTS THE COMMUNITY THAT
JERRY. CAN PLAY A ROLE IN
REBUILDING THAT TRUST.
INMIGRANTE AND GOVERNANCE IS
STRONGER WHEN EVERYONE HAVE A
SEAT AT THE TABLE. FOR THESE
REASONS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
WHERE EITHER TODAY THANK YOUNG.
THANK YU MS HERNANDEZ AND WE
ALSO HAVE BEEN NESSA'S I CAN
ONLY. HOPE POLICY DIRECTOR.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME
BENEFITS BACK NOW WE HAVE SOME
OF THE POLICY DIRECTOR FOR HOPE
WHICH STANDS FOR THE FINEST
ORGANIZED THE POLITICAL
EQUALITY OUR MISSION IS TO
FIGHT FOR POLITICAL AND
ECONOMIC PARITY FOR LATINOS WHO
COMPRISE NEARLY 20% OF
CALIFORNIA'S POPULATION. IT
GOING ACCORDING TO SEVEN POINT
SEVEN TWO MILLION ONE ONE AND
WE ARE PROUD TO SPONSOR SB
SEVEN OH TWO WHICH WILL REQUIRE
THE OFFICE OF THE GOVERNOR TO
RELEASE ON AN ANNUAL BASIS
EIGHT DEMOCRATIC BURKE WERE
ABOLISHED BUT YOU MADE THE
PREVIOUS YEAR. ADDITIONALLY AT
THE SEVEN OH TWO WILL CREATE A
WORKING GROUP THAT IS POSSIBLE
DISCUSSING INFORMING
RECOMMENDATIONS ON THE MOST
EFFECTIVE WAYS TO ENSURE THAT
THE STATE'S LEADERSHIP ON
BOARDS AND COMMISSIONS REFLECTS
THE DIVERSITY OF THE STATE.
THAT DIVERSITY OF THE STATE IN
REGARDS TO RACE GENDER IDENTITY
ETHNICITY DISABILITY STATUS AND
BATTERY. STATUS AMONG OTHER
THINGS. COBIZ EXCITED TO SEE
POP UP ON THE- AT EVERY DAY MY
AND MORE. OF ARE BY IMPORTS
COMMISSION. AND ALSO THE- DID.
PATHWAYS TO THEIR BIRTHDAY AND
ENSURE ACT. OF WHAT ALSO
RELEASED A SIMILAR REQUIRE ON
AN ANNUAL BASIS. TO TRACK
ANALYZE AND RECOGNIZE THAT
PROGRESS THE ANNUAL REPORT IN
THE END SB SEVEN OH TWO IS
NEEDED TO ENSURE. THAT
CALIFORNIA'S OF BILLS ITS
COMMITMENT TO ENSURING THAT
THEY BIRTH IDIOTS CELEBRATED
AND BEST OF ALL FOR THESE
REASONS I RESPECTFULLY ASK. FOR
YOUR ITEMS TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. I LET'S SEE IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE HEARING ROOM
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
C. NINE A MODERATOR IS THERE
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINES
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
I SB. SEVEN OH TWO. ENTITLEMENT
TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR SB SEVEN
ZERO TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
THEY'RE ON YOUR TELEPHONE AT
THIS TIME.WE WHAT DO YOU
CURRENTLY HAVE A FEW ONE MOMENT
PLEASE ALL THE PROVIDER LINE
NUMBERS. BUT A LINE ONE HUNDRED
AND FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
EMILY GOVERNMENT RELATIONS AND
TURN WAY- YOU SEATED AT THE
STATION WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT SB SEVEN A TWO THANK
YOU. NINE ONE HUNDRED AND SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS JOHNNY
CANNELLA ON BEHALF OF UCLA BUT
YOU KNOW POLICY AND POLITICS
INITIATIVE IN SAPPORO SB SEVEN
OH TWO THANK YOU. FIND ONE
HUNDRED AND FOURTEEN A LINE IS
NOW OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS MONICA ONE DANIEL FROM
FOLK AND I SUPPORT SB SEVEN
OKAY. LANE SIXTY TWO YOUR LINE
IS NOW OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS THE
LONG DOOR ON BEHALF OF A TELL
YOU CALIFORNIA ACTION IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU TO MUCH
BETTER LEAN ON BRING. THANKS
FORTY FIVE ELEVEN IS NOW OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON THAT THE BOTTOM
OF IT ON BEHALF OF THE CAMPAIGN
FOR COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY IN
SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN OH TWO
THANK YOU. BRANCH NOTICED A
COMMENT THANK YOU AT THIS TIME.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU ANYONE
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
FROM A REMOTE VIDEO HEARING
ROOM. AT A RATE MOVING TO
OPPOSITION AS THEIR ANYONE IN
HEARING ROOM WHEN SHE TESTIFIED
OPPOSITION. SCENE NINE ANYONE
MODERATOR ANYONE IN THE LINE'S
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. HERE NINE LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. GO AHEAD
SORRY. OKAY GOOD LUCK TO
TESTIFY IN A POSITION FOR SEVEN
OH TO PLEASE PRESS ONE ENTER
WITH THIS TIME. WE HAVE NO
COMMENT AT THIS TIME. IS THERE
ANYONE IN OUR REMOVED VIDEO
TESTER MONEYGRAM YEAH ALL RIGHT
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
MISTER GREG. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR- SENATOR NICE TO SEE YOU.
WE MISS YOU ON THE GREEN CARPET.
YEAH THE- PROCEDURE IN THIS
BILL FORD AND I JUST WANT TO
SAY THANK YOU FOR INCLUDING OUR
REGION. THEN I BELIEVE.
SOMETHING YOU AND I HAVE SHARED
COMING FROM YOU KNOW RURAL AND
AGRICULTURAL COMMUNITIES- WE'RE
JUST SO OFTEN OVERLOOKED I MEAN
LOOK AT THE UC BOARD OF REGENTS
NOBODY FROM THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY- BOARD AFTER BOARD AFTER
WHAT I WAS JUST LOOKING THE
OTHER DAY AT THE NEW CITIZENS
COMMISSION ON REDISTRICTING.
AND SOMEBODY PUT UP A MAP FOR
ME OF WHERE THE COMMISSIONERS-
OUR OUR FRONT END I KNOW YOU'RE
GONNA BE SHOCKED BUT IT WAS A
SMALL CIRCLE AROUND THE BAY
AREA IN A SMALL CIRCLE AROUND
LA AND SOME SURROUNDING
COMMUNITIES WITH THE REST OF
STATE TOTALLY UNREPRESENTED SO
IT JUST AGAIN AGAIN WHICH IS A
PROBLEM I REALLY APPRECIATE YOU
INCLUDING IT I THINK IT'S A
GREAT BILL AND I LOOK FORWARD
TO SUPPORTING IT TODAY. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
AND I AGREE I THINK FOR. THAT
DIVERSITY AND IF YOU LOOK AT
YOU KNOW THE AMENDMENTS IN THE
ANALYSIS- IT DOES INCLUDE MORE
THAN JUST IN THE CITY I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT TO ALSO HAVE
REGIONAL REPRESENTATION- AND
FOR US TO KNOW WHAT THAT LOOKS
LIKE ON BOARDS AND COMMISSIONS.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT. I WOULD
JUST START NEED A MOTION AND A
SECOND. WE GIVE OUR THAT'S
RIGHT WE DID. LISTEN TRACK
THOSE ATTRACTIVE ALL RIGHT
MADAM SECRETARY. WITH MADAM
SECRETARY WE DO HAVE A MOTHER
I'M FROM A FAMILY MEMBER BURKE
AND THE SECOND FROM ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AT RODRIGUEZ YEAH. SB
SEVEN OH TWO THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED. AND REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY.
PETRIE-NORRIS HI PETRIE-NORRIS
I PATTERSON. BURKE BURKE HI
GREAT GREAT I LACKEY LACKEY HI
MEDINA MEDINA HI RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ I. THANK YOU THAT
PULLS OUT THE SENATOR THANK YOU
EVERYONE. ALL RIGHT AT LET'S
SEE AT THIS POINT LET'S MOVE TO
OUR CONSENT CALENDAR FOR TODAY
THAT MOTION AND A SECOND ON THE
CONSENT. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
THE MOTION FROM SOMEONE EVER
AGREED AS SECOND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BURKE SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. CONSENT IS S. B.
EIGHT TWO EIGHT THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
WITH RECOMMENDED.
RECOMMENDATIONS TO CONSENT
CALENDAR PETRIE-NORRIS HI
PETRIE-NORRIS HI PATTERSON.
BURKE BURKE I GREAT GREAT HI
LACKEY LACKEY I MEDINA MEDINA
HI RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ HI.
RIGHT AND WE'VE GOT ONE BILL ON
CALL S. B. SEVENTEEN FROM A
SENATOR PAN SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL GRADE. GREAT I
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ HI OKAY
THANK YOU. HI THERE THE- YEAH.
THE BY. IF EVERYBODY EVERYTHING
FROM WE CAN DO IT FOR. IT WAS
PUT. OUT BY YEAH THE FULL. WHAT
I CAN CALL YOUR NAME PLEASE.
HE'S A NUMBER AND I ASKED THEM.
HE LOST TWENTY SEVEN. OKAY. THE
COMPANY. RIGHT NOW THAT- YEAH.
THE.
THERE WAS. ALL RIGHT WE'LL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR FIVE
MORE MINUTES TO ENABLE ABSENT
MEMBERS TO ADD ON. RIGHT OF
REPLY AFTER. THAT'S BETTER THAN
SOME OF OUR GREAT BUT.
MADAM
SECRETARY IF YOU CAN PLEASE AS
CALL THE ROLL AND UNDER. AWLAD.
LIFT THE CALLS TO ENABLE ABSENT
MEMBERS TAP.
TO PATTERSON
PATTERSON NOT VOTING AND OUR
CONSENT ITEM S. B. EIGHT TWO
EIGHT PATTERSON PATTERSON I.
THANK YOU AT MADAM SECRETARY
THAT CONCLUDES TODAY'S HEARING
OF THE ASSEMBLY IS
ACCOUNTABILITY AND
ADMINISTRATIVE REVIEW
COMMITTEE- WITH THAT WE ARE
TURNED. THE DEPARTMENT OF.
RIGHT YEAH TWO MEMBERS OF THE
JURY CARE ACT OVER HERE. OKAY
YEAH. YEAH OKAY. NINETY SEVEN.
A LITTLE BIT. OKAY PERFECT THAT
WOULD BE. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
YOU'RE WELCOME BUT I THINK YOU.
THE BILL YEAH.